i love sephora
so one of the pleasures that you get
being married as a guy
or even being a relationship is that you
get to learn a lot about makeup and
beauty products
and my wife loves to go out and buy all
this stuff and as guys we get brought
along right we get brought along
and we go into the stores and the first
thing that we look for is a seat
right the first thing you go into a
clothing store a shoe store makeup store
the guys are like oh i don't want to be
here man this is i'm carrying these bags
i don't want to be here i'm looking for
a seat right if i find a seat then
that's a good start the next thing i
look for is wi-fi and if i have wi-fi
and i have a seat
i'm a happy camper you can spend as long
as you want here i'm good i'm chilling i
got my seat i got my wi-fi and this is
why i love sephora's because when i go
in i can usually get a seat i can
usually get free wi-fi
and i'm happy and this is an important
lesson for any company that is selling
to either men or either women you gotta
make the other sex feel comfortable
because what's gonna happen okay for the
stores where i go into with my wife that
i'm not interested in and there's no
seat and there's no wi-fi
i'm gonna be frustrated i'm going to be
following her around
like this
i'm going to be complaining i'm going to
be looking at my my phone looking at the
time right i'm going to be hurrying her
out of there and she's not going to buy
as much and she's not going to have as
much fun there and it's going to put a
downer on our day
so just to make the other person feel
comfortable i'm not asking for a lot all
i want is a chair or a cushion to sit on
and some wi-fi hey wow what if you
offered me a glass of water
wow that would be service can you
imagine getting a glass of water i'm not
asking for the moon here
but that's why i love sephora and
anytime my wife says
hey i need some new mascara i need to go
buy some makeup we should go out and get
some i'll say hey how about we go to
sephora right that's how you generate
business
care about the other sex
you could learn from sephora and love
them too
for other women out there you probably
do for all the guys next time your wife
or girlfriend says let's go buy some
makeup
suggest sephora you have a great
experience
believe
for those who watching like the video
you can subscribe
get more just like it thank you so much
for watching i'll see you soon
and don't forget for my best information
join my newsletter and get on the
believe team today
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun
inspiring and it's the
only newsletter i prioritize and look
forward to period